so I've spoken with no Chomsky who's
been kind of um one of the many people
that are critical of large language
models being able to achieve general
intelligence right and so it's an
interesting question that they've been
able to achieve so much incredible stuff
do you think it's possible that large
language models really is the way we we
build AGI
I think it's part of the way I think we
need other super important things
this is philosophizing a little bit like
what what kind of components do you
think
um
in a technical sense or a poetic sense
doesn't need to have a body that it can
experience the world directly
I don't think it needs that
but I wouldn't I wouldn't say any of
this stuff with certainty like we're
deep into the unknown here for me
A system that cannot go significantly
add to the sum total of scientific
knowledge we have access to kind of
discover invent whatever you want to
call it new fundamental science
is not a super intelligence
and
to do that really well I think we will
need to expand on the GPT Paradigm in
pretty important ways that we're still
missing ideas for
but I don't know what those ideas are
we're trying to find them I could argue
sort of the opposite point that you
could have deep big scientific
breakthroughs with just the data that
GPT is trained on it's like
amazing like if you prompt it correctly
look if an oracle told me far from the
future that gpt10 turned out to be a
true AGI somehow maybe just some very
small new ideas
I would be like okay I can believe that
not what I would have expected sitting
here would have said a new big idea but
I can believe that
this prompting chain
if you extend it very far
and and then increase at scale the
number of those interactions like what
kind of these things start getting
integrated into Human Society it starts
building on top of each other I mean
like I don't think we understand what
that looks like like you said it's been
six days the thing that I am so excited
about with this is not that it's a
system that kind of goes off and does
its own thing but that it's this tool
that humans are using in this feedback
loop
helpful for us for a bunch of reasons we
get to you know learn more about
trajectories through multiple iterations
but
I am excited about a world where AI is
an extension of human will and a
amplifier of our abilities and this like
you know most useful tool yet created
and that is certainly how people are
using it and I mean just like look at
Twitter like the the results are amazing
people's like self-reported happiness
with getting to work with this are great
so yeah like maybe we never build AGI
but we just make humans super great
still a huge win
yeah I said I'm part of those people
like the the amount
I derive a lot of Happiness from
programming together with GPT
uh part of it is a little bit of Terror
of can you say more about that
there's a meme I saw today that
everybody's freaking out about sort of
GPT taking programmer jobs no it's the
the reality is just it's going to be
taking like if it's going to take your
job it means you're a shitty programmer
there's some truth to that maybe there's
some human element that's really
fundamental to the creative act
to the active genius that is in great
design that's involved in programming
and maybe I'm just really impressed by
the all the boilerplate
but that I don't see as boilerplate but
it's actually pretty boilerplate yeah it
may be that you create like you know in
a day of programming you have one really
important idea yeah
and that's the content which is the
contribution and there may be like I I
think we're gonna find
so I suspect that is happening with
great programmers and that gpt-like
models are far away from that one thing
even though they're going to automate a
lot of other programming
but again most programmers have some
sense of
you know anxiety or uh what the future
is going to look like but mostly they're
like this is amazing I am 10 times more
productive don't ever take this away
from me there's not a lot of people that
use it and say like turn this off you
know
yeah so I think uh so to speak this is
the psychology of Terror is more like
this is awesome this is too awesome yeah
there is a little bit of coffee taste
too good
you know when Casper I've lost to deep
blue somebody said
and maybe it was him that like chess is
over now if an AI can beat a human at
chess then No One's Gonna bother to keep
playing right because like what's the
purpose of us or whatever that was 30
years ago 25 years ago something like
that
I believe that chess has never been more
popular than it is right now
and
people keep wanting to play and wanting
to watch and by the way we don't watch
two AIS play each other
which would be a far better game in some
sense than whatever else but that's
that's not what we choose to do like we
are somehow much more interested in what
humans do in this sense and whether or
not Magnus loses to that kid then what
happens when two much much better AIS
Play Each Other Well actually when two
AIS play each other it's not a better
game by our definition of books because
we just can't understand it no I think I
think they just draw each other I think
the human flaws and this might apply
across the Spectrum here with the AIS
will make life way better
but we'll still want drama we will
that's for sure still want imperfection
and flaws and AI will not have as much
of that look I mean I hate to sound like
utopic Tech bro here but if you'll
excuse me for three seconds like the the
the level of
the increase in quality of life that AI
can deliver is extraordinary
we can make the world amazing and we can
make people's lives amazing we can cure
diseases we can increase material wealth
we can like help people be happier more
fulfilled all of these sorts of things
and then people are like oh well no one
is going to work but
people want
status people want drama people want new
things people want to create people want
to like feel useful
um people want to do all these things
and we're just going to find new and
different ways to do them even in a
vastly better like unimaginably good
standard of living world